open up model show girl and actress
sabina kelly is taking over the stage at
harrah's this weekend as she guest stars
in x country
jillian lopez sat down with her ahead of
her performances
okay well the sparkly cowboy boots are
out which can only mean one thing i'm
inside the theater at harris cabaret
with the cast of x country and this
weekend is a really special weekend
because we're welcoming in a special
guest she's a pinup model an actress a
showgirl there's really
nothing she can't do so i'm so excited
to introduce you guys to sabina kelly
sabina we're so excited to see you here
this weekend thank you i'm super excited
to be here and so for people who haven't
seen the show and you're bringing your
own flair to it what can they expect
when they come into the theater oh they
can
expect to have a great time
great music great dancers it's a lot of
fun and let's say you're not a huge fan
of country will you still love the show
you definitely will if you're not a big
fan of country by the end of the show
you probably will be and you have
performed here at the show before and
you've done a lot of things across the
las vegas strip so how does it feel to
just be back on stage bringing smiles to
everyone's face as they come into the
theater it feels so good everybody's
been itching to get out of the house and
so to see the audience back and
everybody having a good time has been an
awesome feeling okay sabina you look
absolutely beautiful in this outfit and
i'm thinking that i want to be part of
the show so i hear you have a little
prop for me is that right i do i have a
hat for you you can put that on and
we'll have amanda teach you how to do
some lasso okay this makes it official
right i got my ex country hat let's head
over here amanda we have a couple other
cast members alongside you and she is
working this lasso over here and i hear
that you're gonna teach me how it's done
is that right yes let's do it jillian
all right i'm gonna switch the mic and
the lasso from you
let's see if i can do it like the pros
the hat has to bring me some good luck
right okay tell me what to do okay so
you're gonna hold it with the handle
with your right hand okay you're gonna
start turning it clockwise okay and
you're going to let the other side go
okay hold on clockwise got it
we got it
oh there we go all right i think i
should be in the show
okay i don't know how much this
qualifies me but i'm going to leave it
to the professionals we're going to end
it they have a fun little performance
plan i'll take the mic from you
see how it's done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so cute you guys does not just make you
want to put your boots on and come out
and see the show sabina come join me
over here be sure to get your tickets
safina is guest starring all weekend
through sunday the show is at 10 p.m i
can't wait to see it congratulations on
everything and be sure to get your
tickets and i think we should all end
with a cute little kiss like you guys i
did you guys ready here we go
i love that x country performs inside
harrah's cabaret thursday through monday
at 10 p.m and don't forget to get your
tickets for this weekend to see sabina
kelly's guest performance rocky